we've got a hypothesis that we're still
working out that's supported to some
degree by the relevant literature so
imagine that you're looking for a stable
partner right so you might think well
what do you want in a stable partner and
at least in principle one of the things
you don't want is too much mismatch
between you and that person on the five
fundamental dimensions so for example if
you're really extroverted and you have a
really introverted partner you're going
to engage in continual conflict about
how much social activity the two of you
should should be should should what
subject yourself to and it's very very
difficult for people who broadly differ
widely differ on those dimensions to
come to consensus because it's not just
a matter of opinion right it's really a
matter of different and if you're
looking at extremes of really different
types of people and the thing about
introverts is they just don't enjoy
large scale social interaction that much
one-on-one they're often fine but in a
group they don't like that and they it
tires them out whereas a real extrovert
it's like you isolate them and and they
just wither on the vine because a huge
part of what actually motivates them in
a positive way is tangled up with social
interaction and so if you're an
agreeable person and you have a
particularly disagreeable partner you're
also going to run into problems because
the agreeable person will say whatever
you want whenever and the agreeable / a
disagreeable person will say well I'd
like to know what the hell you want for
a change and be much more harsh and much
more demanding in the situation and the
agreeable person is going to find the
disagreeable person harsh and unpleasant
and the disagreeable person is going to
find the agreeable person wishy-washy
and unable to stand up for themselves
and again that's a that's actually one
of the primary sources of tension
between men and women because women tend
to be higher in agreeableness than men
it's about half a standard deviation
which is quite quite quite a quite a
large difference by psychological
standards and so what did what that
means I probably haven't got the
statistic quite right but I think I've
got it about right what that means
fundamentally just so you have some
sense of how larger an effect that is is
that if you
have a group of men and women and you
pick out random pairs the woman is going
to be more agreeable than the man 60% of
the time so that's not an overwhelming
proportion but it's reliable and it's
quite it's quite large by psychological
standards so there's the problem with
agreeableness with conscientiousness
well if you're conscientious you're
industrious and orderly and orderly
people seem to be sensitive to disgust
which is something we'll talk about in
detail later we've had a hard time
specifying exactly what makes
industrious people industrious because
it's hard to come up with an animal
model for that sort of thing and there's
no theoretical model but our latest idea
is that my it's not my idea it's
actually the idea of my graduate student
Christine Brophy is that industrious
people find it unpleasant and unsettling
to to not be doing something so it isn't
so much that industriousness makes them
happy or fills them with positive
emotion that would be more extraversion
right because extraversion is the
positive emotion to mention it's that
industrious people can't stand sitting
around doing nothing
and you know it this is speculation but
you know human beings are obviously
always engaged in the exchange of Labor
especially the reciprocal exchange of
Labor and you can imagine that in a in a
community where everyone knows everyone
the people who work hard are going to be
pretty irritated on a fairly chronic
basis with the people who are completely
unproductive
and my suspicions are that plenty of
people who are completely unproductive
in the history of our of the evolution
of our species were wiped out by people
who are unhappy with their lack of
productivity and so I think generally
speaking human beings have this sense of
ethical obligation with regards to one
another to share labor and people who
are conscientious really really feel
that so they feel bad if they're not
busily working on something that's
productive all the time and so the
advantage to being with someone
conscientious is well they're going to
work like mad but the disadvantages is
they're they're going to work like mad
so you know if you're looking for a
partner that you want to relax with or
have fun with or who isn't uptight then
a conscientious person is probably not a
very good choice
on the other hand if you're a
conscientious person and you're living
with someone who's really unconscious
that's good because they might be able
to help you relax but you're not going
to be happy with them because they don't
work nearly as hard as you do but even
worse on the orderly dimension you know
some of you have had roommates and maybe
you're more orderly than your roommate
what does it mean means you're annoyed
by mess before they are and you don't
have to be annoyed by mess much before
you're less orderly roommate for you to
be the one that's always running around
picking things up and so actually one of
the things that's emerged from the
psychometric analysis is that women are
slightly more orderly than men and I
suspect that has something to do with
the on what would you call it
inequitable distribution of housework
because even if your imagine that your
proclivity is to be triggered by
disorder twenty five seconds before your
partner's well you're going to end up it
doesn't take much difference for you to
be the one that's always concerned about
the maths first so anyways and so if
you're a really orderly person and you
live with a disorderly person well good
luck getting along with them they're
going to regard you as like uptight and
and over concerned with details and and
and well and unwilling to relax that's
for sure and they're going to regard you
as well just a bloody mess and how can
anyone possibly live with someone like
you and so so another reason why it's
useful to understand your personality is
because I think it gives you a better
crack at finding someone that you can
actually live with over the long-run and
we don't know what the optimal I don't
think you want to live with someone
who's exactly like you because then both
of you have the same strengths and
weaknesses and there's a bit of a
problem there right because maybe an
agreeable person can use a bit of
disagreeable person around them to
balance each other out and vice versa
right so we don't understand the optimal
balance for for for long term thriving
in a relationship but I think we do
understand the fact that if you're too
different in your traits that those that
where you're different is going to
constitute a chronic source of conflict